bonjour à schiltigheim et merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france
qu'attendez-vous de cette grève demain
on attend une grosse bobine à une grosse
mobilisation de la part des collègues
puisque au vu des dernières annonces du
gouvernement a bien signé à la mort
programmée notre spécialité puisque vous
le rappeliez ses 16 euros nets de
valorisation pour une formation de 18
mois ou une validation d'acquis
d'expérience donc un gros un réel
engagement professionnel et personnel et
aujourd'hui tu y vas partir se former
qui va partir se spécialiser pour une
telle valorisation armées donc vous
rendre revendications principales ce
manque un de reconnaissance de votre
métier infirmiers de bloc opératoire par
le gouvernement qu'attendez vous donc du
gouvernement une nouvelle revalorisation
bien sûr déjà on attend une ré
discussion ça fait plusieurs plusieurs
mois qu'on demande un rendez-vous avec
notre ministre de la santé du cv rang on
sait que demain il sera sur le centre
hospitalier d'avignon
malgré nos demandes successives donc
c'est encore une fois du mépris envers
envers notre spécialité envers notre
collectif et on attend de vraies
discussions et aiderait les engagements
vis-à-vis de notre profession oui
olivier ferrand qui sera au centre
hospitalier d'avignon demain à
l'occasion de l'anniversaire du
lancement du ségur de la santé sur votre
compte twitter vous préciser que ça fait
et vous disiez encore lax cela fait deux
semaines que vous attendez d'avoir un
rendez vous avec le ministre de la santé
mais la visite de demain avignon c'était
pas une bonne nouvelle selon vous ça ne
va rien vous apporter plus bas du
tout-puissant être reçu par des
personnes l'écoutent et nous on veut
vraiment faire un retour d'expérience du
terrain vraiment lui faire un état des
lieux de notre profession puisque on
sait qu'il a reçu plusieurs collectifs
récemment et puis dans l'association à
d'autres spécialités
aujourd'hui c'est un autre tour et on
sait que si on n'est pas reçue demain ça
va être difficile de
contenir nos collègues sur les
différents rassemblements qui aura en
france puisque paris est un droit
rassemblement mais aussi beaucoup
d'initiatives en local je pensais à
toulouse montpellier lille caen et bien
d'autres donc du coup ça va être très
compliqué c'est c'est un début d'un
grand mouvement vous avec en plus la
crise sanitaire la sur-sollicitation
qu'a connue votre profession la
revalorisation des grilles salariales
c'est devenu incontournable
bien sûr la seule variable
le mans aujourd'hui que le gouvernement
a trouvé c'est chez les étudiants
infirmiers de opératoire et dans les
blocs opératoires avec les internautes
bloc opératoire donc c'est les seuls
personnels qu'ils ont réussi à
redéployer dans les services en tension
notamment les réanimations les les
services co vide et aujourd'hui c'est
simple c'est vraiment un impensable ce
qui ce qui vient de se passer avec les
ravages des revalorisations de carrières
qui sont sortis fin avril
vis-à-vis notre profession alors qu' on
était là on a on a géré la crise on a
géré entre les fils puisqu'il faut
savoir qu'on a rattrapés beaucoup
d'interventions tout ce qui a été
déprogrammé au niveau des interventions
chirurgicales
il a fallu rattraper tout ça et on sait
avec cette dernière vague qui vient de
se passer est qu'on a encore beaucoup de
travail à rattraper donc pour nous
c'était c'était juste qu'on nous met en
lumière et surtout qu'on ait une
véritable revalorisation à hauteur de
nos compétences et de nos statuts vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure la mise à mort
vent de votre spécialité dans quelles
conditions travaillent et vous
aujourd'hui quels sont les effectifs
dans les blocs opératoires basse et très
partagés 1 il ya un manque d'effectifs
qui étaient criants dans certains
centres
c'est vrai que au vu du travail fourni
et de la reconnaissance qu'on a derrière
ben malheureusement il ya une fuite des
personnels qui est majeure il ya aussi
il faut il faut le signaler
tiens sanitaire beaucoup d'assignation
invisible de la part des établissements
alors qu'on a lancé le préavis de grève
les directions hospitalières se sont se
sont rués sur les sur les assignations
pourra signer dans nos bons blocs
opératoires à 100% c'est à dire que le
droit de grève est complètement bafouée
ce qui va démultiplie la colère de ceux
qui peuvent se mobilisent
et on espère qu'il y aura d'autres
mobilisations derrière pour faire 3 sur
le mouvement justement une autre
mobilisation nationale est prévue le 15
juin à l'appel de plusieurs
organisations syndicales d'ici là vous
espérez obtenir gain de cause être reçus
par le ministre de la santé olivier
ferrand en tout cas on va tout faire
pour on va tout faire pour se faire
entendre
croyez-nous en tout cas de masse une
journée importante pour nous il va se
passer de nombreuses initiatives et à
paris on va se faire entendre
croyez moi et sur l'appel du 15 juin en
fait partie ddd collectif qui appelle à
la mobilisation le 15 juin pour une
véritable convergence avec tous les
collègues du monde hospitalier
merci beaucoup rachidi goal pour toutes
ces précisions sur cette grève de
mangera tels que vous êtes président du
collectif inter bloc merci à vous